I am Zuri and you're watching another GS  news update  developers Sucker Punch productions has  suffered layoffs today  IGN has reported Sony Computer  Entertainment America confirmed in a  statement to the publication that there  was a reduction in workforce at the  studio  this included developers who worked on  the infamous and Sly Cooper series it is  unknown how many staff were affected by  the change wholly owned by Sony sucker  punch has worked on various games  exclusive to the PlayStation consoles  most recently the studio released  infamous second son for the ps4 a  standalone expansion for the game titled  infamous first flights will be released  later this month what's your favorite  sucker punch game let us know in the  comments below and best of luck to those  affected by the layoffs